let's jump to the story from Insider and
get into the into the meat potatoes here
this PayPal story Insider reports PayPal
Falls after weekend blowback over
misinformation policy that would find
users twenty five hundred dollars the
stock fell six percent on Monday
following the company's botched
acceptable use policy update the company
faced backlash after its updated policy
included a fine of twenty five hundred
dollars for a variety of things but it
included hate speech against
marginalized groups and spreading
misinformation and it said at PayPal's
sole discretion to determine meaning
they could just be like you said the sky
was blue I disagree yoink give me your
money so this resulted in uh PayPal
coming out being like no no it was in
arrows and errors a mistake so the first
thing I want to say
because it affects us several months ago
we took PayPal off timcast.com and we
knew something like this was coming
we've we've seen too much ESG in banking
institutions too much censorship we knew
it was a huge vulnerability so we signed
up with parallel economy when you go to
timcast.com and become a member the
default option is parallel economy
secondary option is stripe Stripes okay
they're not perfect parallel economy is
very very good they're not perfect but
Dan bongino co-founded this to be more
censorship resistant so many people
chose to remain as members using PayPal
I recommend you guys switch over if you
can I'm not sure there's a seamless way
to do it if you when you signed up many
people signed up as guests with a guest
PayPal account that means you just
terminate your account at timcast.com
and then re-sign up but of course that
means you'll get charged 10 bucks again
so if you're in like the middle of the
month
it's it's kind of it kind of sucks I
guess I would say for for for those
that situation wait until your month is
over and then before your charge next
cancel and then switch over or something
like that that would be that that would
be good or if you really don't mind a
couple bucks it does support us because
we we do use it to to you know obviously
uh conduct operations here at timcast
but this was bad and I gotta say right
now
1. trial balloon I certainly think so
they they probably would have ran with
this if there wasn't a major backlash to
it and I think uh I think the other
thing is just well I shouldn't say
there's two things regardless of of the
first uh instance the trial balloon this
will eventually become normal mainstream
they are going to implement this they
just did it with a heavy hand so it's
coming yeah I mean uh absolutely and
PayPal has been doing this for a very
long time they have been weaponized for
the benefit of the political state for a
very long time including originally uh
from when I remember going after Julian
Assange freezing his ability to be able
to collect money online they went after
crypto individuals they went after a
free speech Union they partnered with
the splc a discredited horrible
organization that of course was sued
successfully many times for defamation
and slander of individuals that they
attacked politically so PayPal does not
have the best interest I'm switching
mine I already switched mine to an
alternative I'm switching to more
alternatives because the free market is
where it's at and and PayPal has had a
dominance in the space some people have
said that they are a monopoly I kind of
agree with them because a lot of people
uh have been politically shut off from
PayPal and are unable to to do a lot of
banking online because of that larger
Target put on put on their backs
artificially by PayPal if anyone wants
to know Vanguard BlackRock and State
Street own about 18 of PayPal makes
sense as they do with so many
corporations that are what what about
internationally do they have a lot of
international interests that's that's
what I wonder PayPal no a Vanguard
BlackRock and State Street
I don't know because I I was talking to
a real estate agent we you know
obviously we're expanding we want to do
our brick and mortar shop and the guy
mentioned something about financing for
big properties with like BlackRock I
started laughing and I was like I don't
want to go anywhere near those companies
you know these these things they they do
I don't maybe it wasn't black or maybe
was it different maybe it was Black
Stone Stones doing the housing
developments right right but then
they're like uh but there were there
were similar companies right they're
related in some way yeah the one was a
spin-off of the other yeah yeah what I
see with this is you know we've been
talking about nuclear war and everything
what I see here is
I don't know if if Civil War is the
right word but some kind of look it's
it's policies like this that if they
were to effectively Implement would
result in some kind of I don't know
Insurgency you're if we keep censoring
people if we keep shutting down
businesses if we if if the the doj is
continually going after only one
political faction eventually you get
some kind of disruption and fighting and
destabilization in the United States so
I guess my question to you is do you
think that there is a potential with the
expansion of these kind of policies into
Civil War or revolutionary kind of
Insurgency and fighting within the
country again we talked about Ray dalio
earlier earlier this year mentioning
that he thinks there's a 30 chance of
civil war after the next presidential
election if it's close especially uh the
losing side may say you know I don't buy
it and especially if they continue to be
so split in policies and philosophies I
mean the US is very much a split country
and so you could see I mean I'm in Texas
now in the Texas movement the Texas
leave the United States succeed movement
is is very very big has a lot of support
I mean some polls show most Texans
support getting out of the country wow
so you could see uh you could see the
country falling apart it could happen
now would it be a shooting War I have a
hard time civil unrest I can see I don't
see you know a civil war like our Civil
War uh I just don't think the military
would get involved in that I don't think
they would fight in something like that
so I don't see that kind of a civil war
but I can certainly see uh States like
Texas and you know I personally believe
that the the constitution in my reading
of it is that you don't have to you know
you're not forced to stay in forever and
that's just been a supreme court has
tried to make some decisions since then
but the Supreme Court made it made a
decision in the mid 30s that basically
said you know what screw the
Constitution forget about the 10th
Amendment Congress you can pass whatever
ever you want and spending whatever you
want the Supreme Court basically
nullified the Constitution at least the
10th Amendment in the mid-30s and then
they proceeded to do other things so
yeah there's nothing in the Constitution
that says the state has to stay in the
union forever and Texas knows it there's
there's movements elsewhere so they
could really take off after a bad uh
contested election and if they go
there's no force in the back end the
really odd thing is I could I could
foresee a country like Texas succeeding
and then telling the United States you
know what we're out of your stupid
domestic socialism policies but we'll
stay alive with you we'll continue to
send Texans into the US Military and
we'll be alive with you and if the
Democrats said no to that the next best
thing they could do is Texas could go
you know what let's join the British
Commonwealth
seriously I doubt support the British
Military and we'll go back into the well
the Commonwealth may be less of a bad
fit than being with the Socialist
democratic-controlled United States the
UK not doing too well in that front
they're about 10 times worse than the
Democratic Socialist problems in the
United States correct but in the
Commonwealth they don't have to take
their domestic policies I'm just in
their military I'm talking about for
military and foreign policy not for
domestic policies I don't know maybe it
may be ironic though to have some U.S
states succeed and go back and join the
Commonwealth I don't I don't that one
seems like a long shot but I do see a
possibility of what people refer to as
National divorce or peaceful divorce but
here's the thing about the PayPal stuff
it's a big example of of how we're
getting into this dangerous
authoritarian period the fact that a
financial institution would say we can
take money from your business from your
account regardless if you say things we
don't like that's nightmarish at the
same time stripe emerged and now they're
competing heavily with PayPal locals
which is now Rumble uses stripe parallel
economy emerges
it is bad what PayPal is doing they are
powerful they are dominant but maybe
these uh these alternatives are
inevitable you know when Facebook was
engaging in all the censorship at the
height of uh of 2020 or 2018 and 2019
into 2020. a lot of people were saying
don't worry an alternative will emerge
eventually and many have but I also kind
of think just Facebook is kind of just
dwindling as it is with with uh younger
people and Tick Tock is getting picked
up which is even worse so I don't think
there's always a solution in that the
market will provide but we are seeing at
least when it comes to PayPal the market
here hit them by six percent users are
jumping ship maybe that's the the white
pill moment that's the optimistic thing
that as much as things are getting bad
this PayPal's backlash I'll say this
looks like a de-escalation in terms of
all the stuff well they reversed the
policy which speaks volumes I mean for
them to come out with a bold policy
saying that they're going to steal
Grandma's purse in the middle of the
night as she's walking down the street
as a pretty egregious move for for the
crime of wrong thing it's absolutely
wild that they could try to justify
stealing and theft like a government
would from its citizens as a form of
punishing people for thinking
incorrectly and and I I think yes it's
optimistic that they reversed it but
it's also pretty crazy that they thought
that they could get they could get away
with this that's that's another part of
this that we need to understand here
they thought that this was viable they
thought that this was okay which is
absolutely insane and this shows you how
far they go when it comes to mind
control and when it comes to policing
the thoughts of of American citizens to
the point where they're like we're just
gonna take it off oh yeah get in my head
for a minute I'm an Austrian Banker I
run the bank for international
settlements in Switzerland I'm letting
the U.S survive with my money if I want
to cut them off from my money supply can
the most annoying thing in the world
right now is American republicanism
because they think that they're so great
they think it's they're the best they're
screwing up they're obese they're
screwing up the country I would love
nothing more than to see the United
States split apart a civil war because
that's the biggest threat to my Global
takeover I want to spread my seed I want
everyone using my money I want the bank
for international settlements to be
running the world and the Americans are
annoying men so
that's that that's that perspective of
this global banking cartel that's what
stripe is doing ethereum is the
alternate it's not about dollars and
cents great that parallel economies
using American dollars fiat currency
Federal Reserve notes for now great that
stripe's doing it Stripes still private
I think they're looking at going public
which means blackrock's going to own
them pretty soon I don't know when
that's happening or they've been talking
about it since 2021. people are going to
take that clip of you saying you want to
spread your seat everywhere
I want to inseminate the world with my
Fiat crap but if it looks like ethereum
which is also kind of on a path to Fiat
unfortunately with their transition to
proof of stake now instead of proofs of
proof of work doesn't matter who's
making the currency that matters who has
it they're going to be making more I
don't think it's fiat currency I mean I
mean I'm I'm an ethereum fan and there
are other great blockchains and
cryptocurrency Bitcoin was you know
applaud for being the first but it's not
a very good one and it wasn't expecting
you just to prove the concept but there
are a lot of great cryptocurrencies
which could I mean Zell is the enhanced
as an alternative to PayPal just doing
it with your Zell and your bank but but
the long-term uh Evolution could well be
cryptocurrency that is controlled by no
one other than people using it so the
ethereum their new uh their new uh
process to confirm a block of data and
to lock it in you know you're just it's
people like me I'm one of them now I
have some of my ethereum I've pledged to
go to their system so it's not like a
it's not like I'm pledging US dollars or
fiat currency I'm pledging ether I heard
some rumors that that some people on the
ethereum network were working with like
the world economic forum and their
vision of a centralized currency they
are well this is what I read is that
ethereum is going to be the one world
government coin well it's also important
so by ethereum is what you're saying no
no
financing the monster
you're triggering me here Bitcoin has 19
million Bitcoins 21 million that'll ever
printed they can be broken down in what
are called satoshi's which is the lowest
decimal amount so we have a finite
amount of them they're not Fiat uh in
that sense there's a finite amount but
ethereum can be printed indefinitely as
it's currently standing which means that
you know if enough inflation happens
fast enough you're just going to see an
escalation and a Fiat explosion of
ethereum too
um they could always evolve it create a
fork create ethereum three that's
actually deflationary by nature which I
think is the future of crypto is a
crypto that as long as it sits there
it's constantly degrading in value you
have one today you're losing point zero
zero one percent of that every day so
you're encouraged to spend it you want
circulation of currency you want
currency circulating through any given
system that's what a currency is it's a
current it's a current and just to add
to your point the BlackRock CEO came out
not so long ago and he said this
Ukrainian War could be used to quote
accelerate the use of Central Bank
digital currencies so these fed coins
these these these coins orchestrated by
the federal reserves and central banks
are already being implemented in places
like Canada and Australia the U.S
federal reserve is talking about
implementing one here in the United
States so a lot of people foresee a
deliberate brought on economic Calamity
that's engineered here in the United
States in order to bring on these
centralized digital currencies which of
course will track trace and database and
also create a social credit score like
system that will track how much carbon
you produce that will of course also
punish you for your wrong political
thoughts this is what PayPal is probably
working on on the back end this is what
the Federal Reserve is already working
on and implementing in many other
countries which should scare the utter
crap out of everyone paying attention
right now I think of the it's it's
inevitable that the writing's been on
the wall since maybe the 1980s really
since the Federal Reserve formed and
realized yo we're just going to inflate
this thing until we can't anymore they
have to have some like Future Vision of
what it's going to become and it doesn't
surprise me that it's a global trackable
currency that's digital and can be shut
off with the flip of a switch where did
you see that they said ethereum would be
like that Global Currency if I can find
an article about it who said that it was
some article I was reading uh I don't
disagree
um I was even thinking that it'd be it'd
be Bitcoin the issue is Bitcoin is you
mentioned it was the you know first in
best dress it's it's so it's not
necessarily the best one but it came in
looking good and it worked but the best
thing about it is that it's truly
decentralized and many of these other
cryptos are centralized in some capacity
there was some controversy with a
particular coin I'm not going to mention
because it's proprietary but people were
shocked to discover that they increased
the volume when they said they couldn't
and they did because when you have
centralized digital currency they can
they can control it
did you find it it didn't pop up I'll
see if I can pull it up tonight though
ethereum makes sense I mean doesn't
doesn't ethereum uh no I don't want to
say things I don't know for sure but
ethereum makes sense because it's it's
seemingly the more institutional of the
cryptocurrencies they're getting a lot
of support Bitcoin Bitcoin of course
does but too many anarchists
Libertarians and radicals support
Bitcoin for me to think that's they're
gonna actually try and use that they
want control they also want infinite
Supply ethereum provides a possibility
for an infinite Supply what will happen
is you'll be like you were saying you're
staking the ethereum which means that
you put some into a node and then that
node generates interest I I think it's
actually this I don't know exactly if
it's written into the code of the
ethereum 2 itself that it auto-generates
interest and so it's set to expand at a
certain rate but what will happen is
we'll each have our own nodes people
will probably start selling you little
boxes you plug into your wall and you
tap into with your phone and your
ethereum is going to be on your wall
which is dangerous because someone can
steal that so then we'll create these
like Bank nodes that are like 10 miles
away in a very secure location there's a
node that you can Port into with your
phone where all your ethereum is stored
collecting you interest and then there
will be maybe there'll be a master node
in Bank of international settlements in
Switzerland who knows where they're
going to put the masternode but
eventually they'll start noting up and
then re-centralize the thing no I don't
think they I think it's a surreal
ethereum is a real blockchain it is
decentralized it'll always stay that way
proprietary
um
I mean the problem with Bitcoin is it
takes 10 minutes or maybe more to
process a block so potentially I could
buy something with you paying Bitcoin if
the block doesn't process you know you
don't get paid you may want to win I
don't want to wait 10 minutes for the
block to process Bitcoin is just not
feasible for use but ethereum and as it
advances more can do really fast
processing and can be used for something
like a cryptocurrency that you use
everyday life that is not controlled by
a bank it's controlled by the ethereum
blockchain but if a bank owns 51 of the
chain then or if a cabal of people owns
51 it's not it's not likely but it is a
possibility and I think we should
resolve every contingency when we're
planning a future of Global Currency
like if it can be done it may very well
be done so we should watch out for
people taking control of the nodes
you can track everybody you know with
with Bitcoin uh I believe the ethereum
chain it's all publicly available as
well right all the transactions yeah on
um ether scan I went to I better
self-offs when we talk about uh crypto I
went to Davos several years ago and
crypto was the theme I wasn't in the
actual World economic Forum in the city
of Davos that every all everybody shows
up and then tries to suck all the teat
of the world economic Forum outside of
it to be like look at me look at me I
want to be part of your thing but
there's pop-ups everywhere bars clubs
partying and people do their many events
in the periphery and crypto was it
everyone was like this is the future
this is what we're doing since then I've
been telling people like yo the world
economic Forum types they love crypto
they want that I mean think about what
Bitcoin is it's a arguably a Global
Currency it comes out they get all the
the right wing nut jobs to start using
it and cheering for it they all become
rich overnight this sings the Praises of
it and all of a sudden they're like this
is our way out of the machine and the
Machine is just like oh we love that
everyone's adopting this universe
reversal digital currency that can track
every move you make another reason why
the world economic forum and the global
monetary system doesn't like Bitcoin but
they prefer ethereum is because
bitcoin's energy intensive the mining
process requires that you have a GPU
plugged into a wall it's burning a lot
of coal or whatever your power it
whereas the proof of stake stuff it's
just the digital code on some node
somewhere is just repopulating and
adding new
um gain you know it doesn't require any
mining electricity it's just like in
this program in the in the net the
problem is that the power goes out then
none of it's worth anything right I was
going to ask if the power goes out what
are we going to do yeah when I ask that
question to a group of developers it's
stunned silence
you put the blockchain on on you know
the smoke signal and that's how you
transfer I promise that's how much I had
you send the private key and then you
send the public key and then boom yeah
and everyone can see your private key
and there it is I think cash you got to
maintain cash well we have dealt with
that problem at fortitude Ranch because
we do have a cryptocurrency it's called
the fortitude this is a fake one not the
real and it runs it's an erc20 token
runs on the ethereum blockchain you can
use our tokens to buy membership uh but
what happens if you know the grid goes
down there's no ethereum blockchain you
can't use them so if you want you can
say Hey you know I'm the one who bought
this uh these fortitude tokens I'll put
it on my spreadsheet on my computer I
keep offline and if the Grid's down but
you can still contact me I know that you
know you know you own you know you own
15 fortitudes and you are entitled to
join fortuitude Ranch in because when
the [ __ ] hits the fan for for fortitude
Ranch and every everyone wants to join
we've got a page ready to come up on our
website it says we're no longer
accepting cash memberships you can only
join with fortitude tokens because
people have bought them in the past part
of the allures if you own fortitudes
you're not a member of 42 Ranch but you
we will give you priority to join Over
cash buyers is it I've been selling them
for that is there any kind of like thing
on there where I can scan it and it'll
bring up my fortitude not on this this
is completely a trinket you know for
show but uh you know it's it's a normal
erc20 token so you can see it on the
blockchain if you if you search for
fortitudes frt is our symbol we're hard
to find we're trading frt yeah that's
unfortunate yeah sorry
your company owns most of the tokens we
have people with bottom one to join and
then some of bottomless Investments you
couldn't get FRC
fortitude Ranch currency or Nah
fortitude is the name we use thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there